le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des
Réunionnais dans la vie nous accordons
beaucoup d'importance au fait de laisser
une trace de notre passage ainsi par des
actes par des faits et par l'éducation
que nous pouvons donner à nos enfants
nous continuuons à exister bien après
notre passage sur terre par ses actes
etes combat au sein de la ville qu'il a
administré ainsi qu'au sein du conseil
général un homme illustre parfaitement
cette pérennité et il aura marqué à
jamais les cœurs et les mémoires Roland
Robert un maire dévoué et un conseiller
hors paire on en parle maintenant dans
lien
social Roland Robert aura défendu toute
sa vie ses valeurs ainsi que celles de
la Réunion ses idéos lui auront valu au
début de sa carrière de subir
l'ordonnance de Bré en
1961 l'obligeant ainsi à vivre en exil
loin de son île pendant h longues années
à peine 2 ans après son retour en
1971 il devient maire de La Possession
il occupera ce poste jusqu'en 2014 soit
une durée de 43 ans un record p dans son
mandat à la possession Roland Robert
s'est efforcé de trouver l'équilibre
entre structuration urbaine et
préservation du patrimoine naturel il
fut le premier maire à avoir dès
1979 commencé à travailler sur les
origines du peuplement de la réunion
dont le 350e anniversaire a été célébré
l'an passé il a mis en place des
jumelages avec portlouis antani F
fauchamp et Villeneuve d'Asque grand
défenseur du sport et de la culture il
fut l'un des premiers élus de La Réunion
à réhabiliter le maloya en
1976 ouvrant les portes de sa ville à la
troupe
fondbach mais Roland Robert n'a pas
uniquement été le maire de La Possession
il a également été un élu très actif au
sein du conseil général pendant 41 ans
il occupa diverses fonctions dont celle
de vice-président ducnarm pendant très
longtemps depuis 2011 il était le
premier vice-président du conseil
général en charge de la coopération
régionale et des affaires européennes il
accompagna le c-éveloppement en
permettant à plus d'une soixantaine de
réunionnés avec le soutien du knnarm
d'obtenir des expériences
professionnelles et humaine dans la zone
Océan Indien il avait aussi à cœur de
porter la coopération
dans le domaine de l'eau au profit des
populations isolées ou défavorisé à
Madagascar au séchel ou encore récemment
au
Comor son dernier projet au sein du
conseil général était la mise en place
d'une réelle vitrine de la coopération
décentralisée réunionnaise en mettant en
œuvre une action de développement
intégrée dans la région d'ansirabé à
Madagascar alliant appui à la
Francophonie développement de
l'agriculture et mise en place de
fontaine pour l'accès à l'eau l'action
de Roland Robert fut très vaste tout au
long de sa carrière et de sa vie la
présidente du conseil général Nassima
Dindar a tenu à le saluer c'est un grand
réunionné un grand républicain à la fois
qui s'en est allé je n'ai pu que louer
et je ne peux encore aujourd'hui que
louer sa grande loyauté
la loyauté du vice-président qu'il a été
nous garderons de
lui le souvenir d'un vice-président
grand
travailleur désireux d'apporter sa
pierre à la construction de l'édifice
réunion toujours fidèle au grands
principes qu'il avait modeste
humble militant fidèle à son parti
mais ouvert aux autres plaçant l'intérêt
général de la population au-delà des
contingences partisan Roland Robert
était un idéaliste selon la définition
tandoné Henry Ford c'està-dire une
personnes qui aide les autres à prospér
Roland Robert fait partie de ces hommes
qui ont marqué à tout jamais l'histoire
de notre île ces actes fondateurs sont
la base de l'héritage qu'il nous a
laissé à nous réunionn de perpétuer ses
actions et de maintenir le cap qu'il
avait fixé pour son
[Musique]
île le Conseil Général de la Réunion
vous a présenté lien social le Conseil
général au côté des
Réunionnais